we talked about the best let's talk
about the worst as much as I love Doctor
Who they can't get it perfect every time
so I'm going to look at the bottom of
the barrel when it comes to villains now
because when I did my list of recurring
villains that pretty much covered all
the recurring villains of the card era
this list is going to be made up
entirely of one-timers of the modern era
we got a lot of junk to scrape through
so let's get moving number 10 the mighty
jagrafess of the holy Hydra jessic max
eroding foe this one just kind of
becomes the epitome of insert monster
here there he's got no real personality
the editors a much more effective
villain in the context of that episode
this was just a bigger scary thing
because a dude in a suit apparently
isn't intimidating enough it just
doesn't have a lot of personality it's
not a particularly scary it's just it's
a mouth on a ceiling yet roars it melts
they move along in so shall we number
nine the siren the siren might have
worked better if there wasn't such
reliable tropes in terms of how Doctor
Who deals with what appears to be a
mythological or supernatural creature
it's aliens it's always aliens that's
the way it works so whatever Doctor Who
encounters something that fits into
mythology like a siren into the
mythology of pirates then we know it's
not going to be what it appears to be
it's going to turn out to be something
alien which is exactly what it does I
mean for the story purposes it functions
well enough the notion of the black dot
and then it comes free that's that's and
kind of nifty all things considered but
it's just the way the episode is
constructed it was never going to be
particularly scary and it killed Rory
for what the fourth time already it's
nothing original about this thing number
eight max Capricorn this guy is just so
cartoonish
and I mean that in the most literal
sense he's like a villain out of Captain
Planet you know between the look in the
head in the box and the sneer and the
tooth always glints I mean I get that
they made a joke out of that and that's
kind of funny I guess but it's just so
over-the-top and so overblown and I
can't for the life of me figure out why
he's on that ship I mean he's paid all
the right people to make sure the thing
crashes why is he on there himself it
makes absolutely no sense so he's an
idiot on top of everything else number
seven the best before now I'm actually
fine with this thing for the time in
which it is in human form and its
structure within the story works fine
but a giant wasp really is is that all
that we could come up with I mean did
the monster designer the word were they
just out the week that that thing got
ripped so you just need something really
basic uh giant wasp sharor giant wasp
what it's like a placeholder it's the
sort of thing that you write down until
you think of something better but they
never came back and the fact that it's a
wasp just doesn't feed into the story I
mean I'd let it go if somehow the notion
of a wasp somehow tied to Agatha
Christie's books if like wasp or
recurring motif and her stories or its
toodaloo why why number six the
saturnine here we're dealing with the
exact same problem that we had with the
siren which is that you introduced some
mythological creature vampires in this
case and we immediately know well it's
not what it looks like so what's it
actually going to be in this case it's
fish people I mean even when they're
looking kind of human and the teeth I
mean it's it's an okay look I suppose
now I've seen this before I've seen I've
seen it done better I've seen Doctor Who
do it better then doctor who did its own
spin on vampires way back in the classic
era there was no need to do this sort of
thing again with fish people fish people
I mean they couldn't have even been bats
at least at least that makes sense with
the vampire comparison ah fish sure fish
why not number five the time bug now
this one some people are going to get
upset that it's ranking as far into a
list of worse as it is because as far as
functionally and what it does for the
story it's fine it could completely
kick-starts the story and I'm not as big
a fan of left-turn assembiy bar but it's
a fine story there's nothing wrong with
it but again I've got a same problem
with this thing that I had with the best
perform big beetle that's it
you could cuz the thing is and they show
it in like these tiny glimpses and the
way that they shoot it they could have
come up with something really creepy
because when you get just tiny little
bug then it should have been that sense
of what is that I don't even know what
I'm looking at but we go Oh giant beetle
I mean that's a little freaky sure but
given the way the thing is shot in the
way the story is structured they had the
opportunity to really go wild and go out
of the box to come up with something
genuinely disturbing that we hadn't seen
before and they
stuck a big beetle on her back lazy
number for the hand robots this is
another one where it just has to do with
the small ways that they just fall apart
as far as the overall episode I love
this episode the girl who ate is one of
my favorites but these things design
wise they're okay but they are such a
joke to be taken out seriously that one
shuts down because he has a painting
busted over his head like not even the
painting frame not the wooden bit just
the canvas oh it's just a joke how
insanely easy these things are to take
out and I understand they're not built
for combat I get that but it's like
they're not even built to be able to
bump into a wall accidentally I think it
actually would have made the story even
better than it already is how if they
were a little more difficult to take out
number three
Lazarus now this is one I know I said
before you know really lazy designs I
complained about the best perform I
complained about the time bug well this
is a case where they got a little too
creative and it just kind of went off
the rails this thing falls apart for a
couple reasons
the first is given that the premise is
that this is some sort of earlier what
humans could have evolved into it's just
it's too outlandish the idea that
something like that is locked away in
our DNA I'm having a hard time buying
that they just went too big too
monstrous to not even vaguely resembling
human and then the CGI effects don't
really back it up either
I complain when the design is too basic
and I feel like they weren't creative
they got really creative with this I'll
give them that but it still doesn't work
number two everybody's favorite the
absorb off I don't know what there is to
say about this thing I mean it was
designed by a kid as a contest and you
can tell it's a very kid idea but I hate
loving monsters just like everybody else
I understand what it was trying to do
but it just it was goofy and mishandled
it doesn't balance its elements well the
jokes come off like they're making fun
of fans rather than having a laugh with
them just the whole episodes of messin
and this goofy yeah creature it's just
the icing on a very not tasty cake but
what could possibly be worse than the
absorber
what everyone says is the worst monster
in the history of doctor well I got one
that I think did it even worse
number one the wire this thing just
falls down for me from the word go
concept the execution everything I mean
the only thing that's vaguely creepy
about this is the root is the resulting
people with no face that's a little
creepy but I don't it's never really
mating especially clear what it is
that's happening to them and even though
the results of the people is creepy the
wire itself is not creepies just as
woman on TV going feed me fifty damn
times in our life that's the only thing
she says it hurts to watch I don't know
this actress particularly well I don't
know her work I feel like she was
probably hamstrung by the fact that you
she was obviously just stuck in a box
with one camera how much he possibly
give under those situations well she
shot for the moon and shot herself in
the foot you know the thing could have
had this sort of omniscient feeling if
it was like moving from TV to TV or
somehow traveling in the radio signals
or through the electrical cords you know
give it a um more sense offense but it's
just it's a TV and it sucks your face
while going Phoebe oh shut up I mean the
absorb all off was dumb but at least you
can go I was created by a kid who's it
what's your Excuse on this one really so
there we go
bottom of the barrel that the worst
Doctor Who monsters of the current era
what do you think is the worst monster
or villain that the current era of
Doctor Who has come up with is it on my
list did I get the ranking right did I
miss one completely that you think is
actually worse than any of the ones I
talked about whatever is the case drop
something down in the comments we'll
talk about it and until next time this
council is adjourned